he's pitched outstanding baseball
against the astros the rangers and the
giants
and the good things he's pitched deep in
the ball game something he needs to
continue to do to take the
the load off of the bullpen and his only
win against the marines came this year
the early part of august
here's the pitch on the way swinging a
drive up the middle into center field
for a base hit lead off single for j.p
crawford
and that's the way our ball game begins
and that'll bring up kyle lewis
kyle lewis hits it right to marcus
simeon flipped to second la stella's
there on the first and that's a double
play
so two away here in the first making his
sixth start against the athletics
four last year this is his second this
year record of two and four
making his ninth start overall this
season the lefty
has given up five home runs to the
athletics those coming last year
now the 3-2 pitch and ramon hits a
little tapper back to the mound
taken by kikuchi turns and throws to
first with the out
so these go down one two three and after
one in the first game of the series
the a's and the mariners no score brings
up matt olson and man is it strange to
see a buck 93 next to his name
hit it hard into the shift ty france
doesn't handle it and olson's aboard
second strikeout for you say kikuchi
fans steven piscotti and the a still
have runners on it second and third but
now with two down
the fish to jake lamb and jake it's a
high pop up on the infield
gonna carry in a short left field a long
run for lopes a left fielder
and going out the shortstop crawford is
there and he makes the catch in short
left so lamb pops out
and he has failed to capitalize here's
marcus simeon with one out
hit well to right center field long run
for everybody involved nobody's going to
get it
lewis plays it off the wall marcus
simeone has a one-out double
so perfectly placed in the gap nobody
could get it ball carried very nicely an
easy double for him and that goes to
being up and over the fence for a home
run
but a great approach by marcus simeon
and trying for third is marcus simeon
and he is out
so the ball just rolled away from odom
not real far
marcus trying to get to third with one
out so you know what he's thinking
he's going to end up reaching around the
leg of teddy barrett as opposed to
shuffling him and moving him you see
that little tap right there
that allows him to navigate around
efficiently france coming over
from san diego hit 309 for them
scoreless in the fourth two outs nobody
on for the mariners the pitch
fastball strike three on the outside
corner 94 with movement
and a one two three inning for chris
baston as he collects his third
k of the night so davis a little bit out
in front five four three double play
two outs with cannon now at third long
lead
for canada down the line to third swanna
bouncer up the first baseline
white gets behind the bag on the
backhand makes the catch flips the
kokuchi covering and the a's again
have two one with nobody out and they
come away empty-handed
so that'll bring up tim lopes there's
the o2 pitch now and that's the swing of
the ground ball to shore charging simeon
near the bag at second throws to first
and bassett
a one two three top of the fifth and
halfway through our ball game tonight
after four and a half he is in the
mariner is nothing nothing
so one away here's murphy here's the
stretch and the 2-1
pitch swaying in a hot shot one hopper
to third snared by seeger he's got it
toss across in time to get murphy for
the second out of the inning what a play
by
kyle seeger half step to his left he was
able to go
get it hot corner living up to its name
with that play right there a one-hopper
skipping to his left
it's nothing nothing the mariners
threatening we're in the top of the
sixth they have runners at first and
second
see if sega can pick up a run he's one
for two seeger the open stance pass it
curveball is a high pop up
but stella and short right now coming in
just to the rim of the outfield grass
he's there and he makes the catch and
the inning
is over and bass it works out of a great
job again tonight
well he's been up to a number of
challenges in this ball game he's
pitched around a one-out double in the
30
pitched around a lead off double in the
fourth he deals swinging it's pulled
into shallow right field france tackles
it throws from a knee in right picked by
white near the chalk at first
and olson is retired tricky play ty
france in right field makes it happen
and it gets usaid through six scoreless
in oakland
joseph odom will be coming up petite
throws and odom it's a high five ball
left center wellhead grossman going back
in the alley at the track right to the
wall he's there
and he makes a good catch scaling the
wall in deep left center field
an excellent play by robbie grossman he
gets into a shadow
feeling for the wall as he elevates at
the same time very difficult one check
wall ball wall you know the rookie heim
is batting a 235
the stretch and the one-nothing pitch
swing and a well-hit ball deep to left
field on the run and with a leap at the
end of the run
tim lopes makes the catch holy smokes
what a fine running catch way out there
in left field down the line by tim lopes
the mariners get the runner at third
with one out
and now here comes evan white infield
indeed third scoreless in the 10th the
3-0
swinging a miss and in fact it gets away
from murphy here comes d
he slides across the plate slip and
slide style of the mariners get the
first
run of the night and the ace tying run
down 90 feet away but they're going to
need
something to happen with two outs to
either extend or win this game from
ramon loriano
loriano lines it left field and that's
going to get down for a hit
orth will score loriano is going to dig
for second and the a's have tied it here
in the bottom of the 10.
in the air to right fields hit pretty
well bishop going back bishop's still
going back
and that baby is gone
the a's have walked it off in extra
innings